[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à ce débat
consacré à la Jeunesse et à la
citoyenneté donc avant de vous présenter
nos intervenants peut-être quelques mots
sur le contexte comme vous le savez
depuis depuis quand déjà pas mal
d'années nous connaissons une abstention
très forte de l'ensemble des Français
aux différentes élections et
particulièrement de la jeunesse et
malheureusement ce constat c'est
largement confirmé je dirais même
amplifier en 2022 2022 qui était
l'élection comme vous le savez de la
présidentielle et législative donc pour
parler de ce sujet je vais vous
présenter nos deux intervenantes vous
allez voir qu'en réalité nous sommes
quatre mais je vous l'expliquerai dans
un second temps donc tout d'abord
bienvenue à vous Cécile Céline pardon
braconnier vous êtes directrice de
Sciences Po Saint-Germain-en-Laye donc
pas très loin des pas très loin d'ici et
professeur de sciences politiques vous
êtes depuis de nombreuses années
spécialisées sur toutes les questions de
participation électorales d'abstention
et notamment de la de la jeunesse
autre intervenantes Frédéric Len merci
également de votre présence bonjour vous
êtes mère adjointe à la jeunesse de
Suresnes donc dans les Hauts-de-Seine
donc sur Rennes depuis déjà plus de 20
ans vous avez mis en place un Conseil
communal de la jeunesse donc il en
existe beaucoup dans les communes
françaises mais peut-être que le vôtre a
des spécificités dans dans son mode
d'organisation et pour voir ça
concrètement vous êtes vous n'êtes pas
venu seul vous êtes venus accompagner de
deux de deux jeunes donc Yasmine et
Arthur et en plus les assidus parce que
une des spécificités doit être votre
conseil c'est de pouvoir être présent
depuis plusieurs années ce qui n'est pas
le cas dans tous les conseils municipaux
de jeunes en France et Yasmine est très
assidu ce que c'est sa sixième année et
Arthur 3 ans
donc peut-être avant de vous donner la
parole
je me tourne vers c'est une braconnier
pour revenir peut-être à ce à ce
contexte général
en effectivement particulièrement les
jeunes et pas dire les solutions c'est
malheureusement pas aussi simple façon
il y a pas eu s'il y a des solutions il
n'a pas eu de mais plusieurs et c'est un
long combat mais vous ne manquez pas
d'idée en tout cas je vous donne je vous
donne la parole donc déjà pour revenir
peut-être sur ce contexte et sur l'année
qui l'année 2022 qui a confirmé ça
oui l'année 2022 a confirmé l'ampleur de
l'abstention électorale et
l'accentuation de l'écart de
participation des jeunes par rapport au
reste de la population c'est assez
fascinant parce que quand l'abstention
augmente elle attend toutes les
catégories mais on pouvait penser que
les inégalités de participation
notamment liés à l'âge à les atténuer et
c'est pas du tout le cas donc plus
l'abstention augmente plus l'écart de
participation augmente au détriment des
jeunes ils sont de moins en moins à
voter ils ont été environ un quart à
participer au législatives aux dernières
législatives juste une chose quand vous
dit John c'est jusqu'à 24 25 ans on peut
aller jusqu'à 35 ans en matière de
participation électorale le taux de
participation ne commence à augmenter
vraiment qu'à partir de 35 ans bon ça
c'est le facteur H vous avez eu raison
d'insister tout de suite sur le l'aspect
multifactorial de de qui qui explique
cette situation le facteur âge on a
toujours plus voter à 40 ans qu'à 25
parce que tout simplement à 25 on est
dans un âge de transition on sait pas
encore où on va on n'est pas forcément
intégré dans un dans un dans un travail
on n'a pas encore de famille et donc
tout ça fait que on est moins enraciné
disons dans des formes d'intégration
sociale et on participe moins à la à la
vie de la de la cité et encore moins de
façon institutionnelle que de façon plus
informelle on pourra on pourra y revenir
mais il y a plein d'autres facteurs et
parmi ceux qui apparaissent très
important et dont on peut discuter au
regard du du plateau qu'on a aujourd'hui
figure l'école il y a une vraie
indétermination vous êtes sévère sur
l'école qui remplit pas son rôle par
l'école je suis sévère à l'égard de
l'école disons que on se rend compte
qu'il y a à la fois au sein de notre
jeunesse un besoin de comprendre le
fonctionnement institution et un besoin
de sens pour se rendre aux élections
c'est tout à fait frappant de constater
que les jeunes contrairement à ce qu'on
attend à ce qu'on entend dire parfois de
se désintéresse pas de la cité y compris
des institutions de la cité mais
expriment très fortement
une incompréhension de du fonctionnement
institutionnel il y a un besoin de sens
et contrairement à ce qui se passait il
y a encore 30 ou 40 ans les jeunes qui
vont beaucoup plus à l'école qu'avant
n'accepte plus d'aller voter ou de
participer sans comprendre le sens
finalement ils ne vote pas produire de
vote aveugle et il n'accepte de
s'engager qu'à la condition de
comprendre et qu'à la condition de
rencontrer une offre qui correspond à
leurs aspirations quelque part ils sont
beaucoup plus exigeants cette génération
là à l'égard de la politique notamment
institutionnelle que ne l'étaient les
générations précédentes
25 à 50 à 75%. alors c'est réconfortant
mais ça nous alerte très fortement il
est encore temps de redresser la barre
évidemment mais il faut se poser les
bonnes questions répondre à cet
aspiration à la compréhension et la
compréhension ça passe par l'école
d'abord même si il y a d'autres espaces
où les jeunes peuvent apprendre et
comprendre en expérimentant les
institutions mais ça passe d'abord par
l'école pourquoi parce que l'école est
obligatoire jusqu'à 16 ans et donc c'est
un moyen de toucher tous les jeunes tous
les jeunes pas seulement son ceux qui
évoluent dans des familles grâce
auxquelles grâce auxquelles ils vont
être politisés plutôt pas seulement ceux
qui accompagnent leurs parents dans les
bureaux de vote dès le plus jeune âge
pas seulement ceux qui vont avoir la
chance de participer à ces conseils
municipaux de la jeunesse et autres
expérimentations tout intéressantes il
faut
viser l'école parce que l'école touche
l'ensemble des jeunes et il y a dans
cette ABS attention qui augmente une une
très très forte inégalité
sociale notamment de participation qui
expliquent que au fur et à mesure que
les jeunes désertent les urnes déserte
les unes en particulier les jeunes les
plus en difficulté sociale ce dont les
parents ne sont pas du tout politisés ce
dont les parents sont eux-mêmes très
loin des institutions et seul l'école a
une capacité de redonner du sens et
d'expliquer le fonctionnement des
institutions d'accompagner vers les
urnes d'accompagner les premières
expériences électorales de tous les
jeunes c'est très important notre
démocratie elle a vocation à être
inclusive on ne peut pas se résigner de
voir que dès le plus jeune âge dès la
majorité une grande partie des électeurs
voilà ne vont pas voter encore qu'il
faudrait rentrer dans le détail parce
que l'élection présidentielle a encore
une capacité en France à mobiliser
10% des plus jeunes donc on n'est pas
dans une situation de rupture avec les
institutions mais on est dans une
situation de prise de distance à l'égard
des institutions et il faut se poser les
bonnes questions et savoir comment on
s'appuie sur l'énergie qu'on les jeunes
sur l'envie de participer qu'on les
jeunes pour retisser du lien et que
cette énergie elle s'investisse aussi au
bénéfice de nos institutions pour
revenir sur l'école parce que vous
employez le présent et puis une fois ça
serait le conditionnel parce que on voit
que ça ne se fait pas malgré le fait
qu'il y a qui a des programmes qui
devraient être qui devrait traiter de
ces sujets là et on sait que c'est trop
c'est trop c'est trop timide il y a quoi
il y en a une inquiétude institution
scolaire d'une que la que l'école se
polititise est-ce que c'est quoi
l'explication oui alors ce qui est sûr
c'est que il y a un paradoxe en France
puisque on est le pays européen dans
lequel il y a plus d'heures
théoriquement consacrées à l'éducation
morale et civique
donc voilà en théorie dans les textes
tout va bien
là où ça va moins bien c'est quand on
regarde comment ça se passe dans la
pratique dans la pratique les
professeurs ne sont pas formés au sein
même des programmes d'éducation morale
et civique les institutions occupent une
portion très très minime les professeurs
en n'étant pas formés en ayant peu
d'outils pédagogiques à disposition sont
très mal à l'aise dans la présentation
des institutions et de façon générale
quand elles sont présentées par les
professeurs qui sont un peu plus engagés
que que les autres et qui sont moins
timides elles le sont de façon trop
théorique et donc elles alimentent un
sentiment chez les jeunes souvent de
décalage avec la réalité que certains
peuvent percevoir par exemple à la
télévision sur la façon dont fonctionne
nos institutions je vous donne un
exemple très parlant quand on regarde
des débats parlementaires ce qu'on voit
c'est ne serait-ce qu'hier soir c'est du
conflit du conflit d'idées de
l'opposition c'est complètement gommé
dans la façon dont on peut présenter les
institutions à l'école en présence des
schémas institutionnels aussit après
qu'ils aient été prisés
et voilà pourquoi je vous prépare votre
transition pour nos autres invités voilà
pourquoi il est très important d'avoir
des expériences qui mettent en présence
les jeunes et des institutions incarnées
dans des élus c'est irremplaçable la
question qui reste posée étant notre
capacité à étendre ces expériences à une
grande partie de la Genèse et non pas à
seulement quelques élus parce que ce
qu'on a aujourd'hui comme
expérimentation pratique de
socialisation politique d'accompagnement
vers vers la participation civique ça ne
profite qu'à quelques enfants et ça
constitue en quelque sorte des filières
de pré-recrutement des professionnels de
la politique quand vous faites des
sociaux graphies du monde politique
aujourd'hui vous vous aperçu que là vous
vous apercevez que la plupart de nos
élus ont été délégués de classe et la
plupart du temps plusieurs fois et donc
ce qui se passe c'est très bien d'avoir
délégués de classe et il faut évidemment
poursuivre mais
quand ça ne sert en réalité quand ça ne
se prolonge que par la préparation d'un
petit noyau de spécialiste de la
politique il faut poser la question de
la capacité de ces spécialistes dont on
a par ailleurs besoin à entraîner les
autres et donc l'expérience accumulée
dans les conseils municipaux de la
jeunesse ou en tant que délégué de
classe elle a évidemment un sens mais il
faut travailler à l'entraînement du plus
grand nombre et donc questionner le rôle
qu'on laisse à ces élus à ses élus
enfants à ses élus plus jeunes notamment
en dehors un de la prise en charge plus
globale de l'éducation à la citoyenneté
pratique que l'école devrait prendre en
charge merci je vous demanderai une
réaction aussi sur ce que vous allez à
entendre donc Frédéric lehlem comme je
le disais vous êtes mer adjointe à la
jeunesse de Suresnes peut-être revenir
quelques quelques mots sur gisais ça
déjà plus de 20 ans donc il y a déjà un
historique donc je pense des adaptations
aussi de votre conseil communal de la
jeunesse peut-être en quelques mots nous
nous expliquer son mode de
fonctionnement et et voir peut-être son
adaptation au fil du temps alors
effectivement le conseil communal de la
jeunesse de Suresnes à 23 ans il a été
créé à une époque où très peu de
conseils étaient présents dans les dans
les communes et nous avons fait le choix
de d'impliquer au maximum les jeunes de
les écouter de les faire se confronter
aux différentes missions
aux exigences de la vie collective de
les accompagner avec des encadrants
formés et spécialisés pour les leur
permettre de leur offrir une formation à
plein temps qui les encadrent et les
exactement le cas de tous les conseils
nous avons fait le choix très judicieux
d'avoir une personne qui est responsable
à temps plein des jeunes du CCJ qui est
donc là pour les accompagner les former
animer les différentes réunions mais
également faire le lien avec les
familles parce que c'est aussi très
important d'impliquer les familles dans
dans toutes les activités dans tous
leurs projets qui mettent en place et
sur le nombre alors ils sont assez
nombreux par rapport à d'autres cons là
vous envoyez deux mais il faut savoir
que au total ils vont être 77 là à
partir de de la rentrée nous avons 44
jeunes qui sont élus en CM2 dans les
différents établissements scolaires il y
a donc quatre
membres du CCJ par école élémentaire et
puis
les suivants les 33 autres
sont des jeunes qui vont donc du de la
sixième à la terminale et même plus
puisque ça va jusqu'à 20 ans et c'est
jeune là sont membres mais ils sont
volontaires c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont
choisi de d'être membre du conseil
communal de la jeunesse donc pour les
pour les plus jeunes vous organisez des
élections donc à l'école exactement
alors justement notre animatrice
référent du CCJ est en lien avec tous
les établissements scolaires
toutes les établissements élémentaires
elle passe dans chaque classe pour
expliquer le rôle du CCJ pour expliquer
les attentes comment ça va se passer les
modalités et suite à cela les écoles
donc il y a un partenariat avec les
enseignants ce sont eux qui organisent
les élections au sein de leur de leurs
établissements et ensuite ils viennent
toujours beaucoup plus les CM2 sont des
élèves qui sont très très volontaires
tous les jeunes ont énormément d'idées
donc ils sont toujours très très
participants et ils sont force de
proposition pour amener plein de
solutions pour améliorer la vie les
enseignants ça a été dès le départ ils
ont joué le jeu ils ont trouvé que
c'était une idée intéressante évidemment
c'est un travail de partenariat donc il
a fallu effectivement petit à petit
rentrer dans les établissements et
maintenant comme notre référente est
bien identifiée donc il y a plus aucun
souci il y a vraiment une confiance qui
s'établit entre les deux et donc
forcément le partenariat marche de tant
mieux c'est intéressant que ça se passe
dans l'école ça rejoint un peu ce qu'on
disait à l'instant donc ça fait une
jonction intéressante disons je voulais
même rajouter qu'effectivement l'idée
c'est que comme vous avez dit dans les
écoles c'est compliqué de de d'installer
ce genre de de
mode de participation
notre référente forme les animateurs du
périscolaire pour que le modèle du CCJ
puisse être répliquée dans les temps
périscolaires que ce soit le mercredi ou
bien les vacances scolaires
oui donc d'élargir et de toucher un
public plus large donc exactement l'idée
c'est effectivement de toucher tous les
jeunes qui fréquentent les
établissements scolaires de la ville et
non pas simplement une petite partie des
jeunes qui pourraient se sentir capable
d'être élu auprès de leur père et
d'intégrer les le conseil communal de la
jeunesse mais également tous ceux qui
pourraient se dire bah voilà je petit à
petit je me sens capable et moi aussi je
vais me lancer et pourquoi pas commencer
par aller rejoindre un conseil de jeunes
du périscolaire avant d'intégrer
éventuellement le CCJ l'idée de ce
conseil communal c'est évident que ça
traite un peu de tous les sujets je sais
que vous avez cinq commissions donc dont
une sur l'environnement la citoyenneté à
la récure mais au-delà des différentes
thématiques votre idée c'est vraiment de
de forger une citoyenneté de chez
ces jeunes excusez-moi parce que ça leur
explique aussi le fonctionnement d'une
collectivité d'une commune que les
choses ne sont pas aussi simples que
d'avoir un projet et de le mettre en
oeuvre après il y a la sa faisabilité
son financement donc qui doit être voté
aussi en conseil municipal alors
effectivement l'idée c'est que les
jeunes soient au maximum au confrontés à
toute la vie de la d'une commune c'est à
dire que le projet il est évidemment
proposé par les jeunes il est discuté
ils avancent sur leurs projets il y a
effectivement du lien qui va être fait
avec le maire que ce soit avec aussi les
élus concernés en fonction des
thématiques abordées donc tout ça c'est
un apprentissage les jeunes apprennent
la méthodologie de projet mais après
également toutes les contraintes d'une
collectivité comment ça se passe comment
est-ce qu'on doit faire à qui on doit en
référer et donc
sur certains projets ils vont rencontrer
les services sur sur place
également là on a un projet sur des
passerelles pour les écureuils et bien
le les services techniques de la ville
sont présents avec les membres du
conseil communal de la jeunesse pour
établir avec eux l'emplacement toutes
les modalités
peut-être un mot parce que là ils ont
des écharpes alors c'est pas la même
écharpe qu'un AER au Canadien mais
expliquer pourquoi parce que dans le
processus il y a plusieurs moments dans
l'année où ils vont rendre compte si je
puis dire et échanger au conseil
municipal et je crois qu'au début de
leur de l'installation du Conseil on le
met leur remet ses écharpes exactement
une fois que les élections des cem2 a eu
lieu un séminaire de rentrée avec tous
les jeunes est organisés donc sur une
journée vraiment ils ont une journée
complète dédiée à le CCJ qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont faire ils vont commencer à
émettre les projets qui qui ont envie de
mettre en place et à la fin de la
journée une cérémonie officielle avec
Monsieur le Maire qui va leur remettre
leur écharpe devant leur famille
présente mais également les tous les
élus de la commune donc on a voulu que
ce soit un moment
institutionnel et vraiment quelque chose
qui qui les marque aussi dans leur
entrée dans la chine-voyenneté
exactement pour qu'il puisse
comprendre que voilà il rentre vraiment
dans une institution
et donc ils sont là pour apprendre
également et comprendre tous les tous
les tenants et les aboutissants lorsque
l'on mène un projet peut-être donner un
donner le micro elle l'a déjà elle s'est
préparée Yasmine comme je disais Yasmine
c'est déjà sa sixième année donc elle
elle connaît bien et c'est le début
d'une longue carrière justement une
question sur cette écharpe est-ce qu'il
y a une fierté de cette écharpe au-delà
de la symbolique
d'avoir cette écharpe depuis six ans
c'est forcément une fierté pour moi et
même ma famille de pouvoir représenter
la ville de réaliser des projets de
pouvoir incarner en fait cette image de
la jeunesse dans la communauté et dans
cette collectivité territoriale de ma
commune de pouvoir réaliser des projets
qui qui est
nécessairement touche tout le monde ça
soit les jeunes comme les plus âgés etc
ma question aussi c'est 77 jeunes dans
le conseil est-ce que on sent qu'ils
sont impliqués au-delà des deux qui sont
là ils sont impliqués passionnés mais
est-ce que ça SMS au-delà est-ce qu'il
sait des ambassadeurs aussi auprès de
leurs amis
alors effectivement partir du moment où
on va avoir des jeunes qui se
fréquentent tous des établissements
scolaires qui fréquentent des
associations et bien il
avec leur père et peuvent effectivement
expliquer ce qu'ils font au sein du
conseil communal de la jeunesse et à
terme petit à petit il y a des jeunes
qui viennent qui intègrent le conseil
communal de jeunesse parce qu'ils ont
entendu parler de ce qui se passe ils
ont entendu parler des différentes
des différents projets qui peuvent être
mis en place et ça donne envie
effectivement à d'autres jeunes de
pouvoir s'impliquer également
et justement par rapport à allez je vais
donner la parole à Arthur parce qu'il va
se sentir des favorisés alors Arthur il
a il a 12 ans et c'est déjà sa troisième
année donc il va rattraper Yasmine dans
l'acidité alors je sais que c'est dur de
se projeter tu as 12 ans mais est-ce que
tout ce travail là on est on a sa
majorité à 18 ans est-ce que ça
donnerait envie de de continuer
peut-être en étant candidat sur des
listes aux municipales
est-ce que tu as envie d'un prolongement
comme ça tu penses ou c'est trop tôt
chaque chose en son temps
en fait j'ai pas vraiment pensé
sérieusement mais en fait je me suis
inscrit au conseil communal de la
jeunesse parce que j'étais très
intéressée pour voir tous les métiers
des personnes comme ici on voyait tout
ce que les personnes faisaient mais je
me suis pas encore vraiment projeté dans
le futur pour savoir si j'allais faire
de la politique ou pas
16 16 ans 17 ans 16 ans je crois donc 18
ans ça se rapproche pas pour autant que
tu vas être lendemain candidat sur quoi
que tu me diras les prochaines
municipales c'est 2026 donc tu as le
temps de te préparer ou peut-être
d'autres élections est-ce que c'est
quelque chose auquel tu penses ou ça te
paraît un peu incongru comme idée c'est
vrai que c'est une possibilité de
parcours et j'aimerais ça m'intéresse
vachement
tout ce qui est dans le domaine de la
politique etc dont Sciences Po je
j'avais une idée de faire sans ce point
à un moment donné mais c'est vrai que
c'est assez intéressant de pouvoir voir
différents métiers
qui incarne vraiment la politique et oui
pourquoi pas
et justement par rapport à question que
je posais à Frédéric Len est-ce que par
rapport à tes amis est-ce que tu
prêches la bonne parole si je puis dire
est-ce que vous par rapport à des fois
mes connaissances ou des a priori un peu
de ce qu'on a pu entendre comme ça
est-ce que tu es là un peu pour défendre
de dire c'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe c'est super important
c'est vrai que parfois il y a des
moments où on passe à la télé on est
dans le journal dans le magazine de
Suresnes j'ai été en affiche de la ville
etc la ville etc c'est vrai que c'est
vrai que parfois il y a pas mal de
jeunes qui me disent mais comment tu as
fait qu'est-ce que tu fais pourquoi
comment il se pose pas mal de questions
et c'est vrai que c'est là où ça on
remarque ça les intrigue et c'est là au
moment où on peut essayer d'expliquer
qu'est-ce que c'est que le Conseil
communal de la jeunesse qu'est-ce qu'on
y fait pourquoi etc et c'est vrai que
essayer un peu de défendre de presser la
belle parole et de pouvoir exprimer un
peu
qu'est-ce qu'il y a la politique et
pourquoi je suis dans ce domaine là
[Musique]
à tous les échelons les lycées s'ouvrent
les universités s'ouvrent sur leur
territoire de plus en plus de liens sont
tissés entre eux donc les élus et les
institutions d'enseignement et donc ça
favorise l'investissement par exemple de
l'espace école pour de l'apprentissage
civique pour de l'accompagnement
de cet apprentissage notamment dans le
temps périscolaire je trouve ça très
intéressant que vous ayez pensé en même
temps que le Conseil des enfants des
formes de répliques qui sont des sortes
de SAS mais organisées dans l'école donc
plus visible par davantage par davantage
d'enfants dans tous les cas c'est
intéressant ce qu'on voit c'est que même
dans le cas de l'éducation morale et
civique ce qui fonctionne ce dont les
jeunes se souviennent c'est quand il
rencontre un élu ou quand il voit un
film et que l'institution est incarnée
qu'ils assistent à des débats bon
parlementaires principaux dans n'importe
quel arène institutionnelle et que ça se
traduit assez concrètement ça c'est un
premier élément on sait qu'il faut aller
vers de l'apprentissage beaucoup plus
pratique pour quotidien
il savait pas ou des fois on se dit
c'est l'état où on sait même pas qui
c'est et là moi j'avais envie de
demander
à Yasmine et Arthur s'ils avaient un
exemple qui les avait particulièrement
marqué d'action à laquelle ils ont été
associés en tant que élu des jeunes de
leur ville voilà pour qu'on se rende
compte de ce qui font concrètement dans
ce conseil bonne question et après
malheureusement on va je crois finir par
ça Yasmine peut-être et bien moi c'est
vrai que je participe pas mal à des
collègues solidaires donc en lien avec
des associations comme les Restos du
Coeur la Croix Rouge etc et c'est vrai
que c'est c'est l'une l'un des projets
qui me tient pas mal à cœur parce qu'on
peut sans nous forcément donner mais
propager l'idée de donner propager
l'idée de de collecter pour des fonds et
pour donner et je trouve que c'est un
beau projet et que c'est ça vraiment ça
me tient vraiment à coeur parce qu'on le
fait assez souvent on le renouvelle
assez souvent et c'est ça marche très
bien
et Frédéric Len vous me disiez que
souvent les jeunes qui sont passés ou
qui sont encore dans dans le conseil
souvent il y a un engagement associatif
alors c'est pas forcément celui dans tu
parlais un instant mais que ça les
booste aussi dans à s'engager dans une
association d'avoir cette citoyenneté
c'est ça aussi oui tout à fait à partir
du moment où ils ont pu mener à bien des
projets qui se sont investis aussi bien
enfin en temps c'est à dire que ça leur
demande beaucoup beaucoup de temps ils
ont des réunions ils sont très présents
sur le terrain
il garde même en quittant le conseil
communal de la jeunesse il garde cette
culture de du bénévolat de l'engagement
et on les retrouve évidemment beaucoup
plus dans des associations ou autres
lorsqu'ils sont à l'âge adulte ou même
plus tard
et peut-être un mot Arthur parce que tu
avais été aussi questionné est-ce que tu
penses à quelque chose de précis sur
lequel tu sens que tu as eu un peu de
prise
j'ai beaucoup apprécié quand on a
travaillé avec le Mont Valérien et la
crypte du Mont Valérien par exemple
l'hiver dernier on avait nettoyé
l'esplanade du Mont Valérien un matin et
toute l'après-midi on avait accueilli
les personnes à la crypte pour faire
visiter ce qu'on voit presque pas parce
que c'était que quelques jours après
l'inhumation du berger allemand dans la
cuisine
et donc ça ça tu savais les choses qui
s'étaient passées à cette époque ça t'a
appris aussi des choses au-delà de la
symbolique du souvenir aussi de la
mémoire oui j'ai beaucoup appris parce
qu'on a fait plusieurs visites de la
grippe du Mont Valérien par exemple la
journée du patrimoine on a tout visité
et plein d'autres jours par exemple au
séminaire de rentrer on a eu la chance
de visiter la crypte
on arrive on arrive vraiment à la fin un
dernier mot parce que je vous ai vu vous
vouliez avoir une réaction Céline
braconnier
aussi comme des incitations à
l'engagement des des jeunes et rappeler
que les chiffres sont quand même pas
extraordinaires
sur sur le bénévolat notamment pour les
plus jeunes puisque si plus de 40% des
des jeunes sont membres d'une
association on n'a que 19% de notre
18-25 ans qui sont bénévoles ou qui sont
actives dans ces années
alors c'est pas moins qu'avant mais
c'est moins que de jeunes qui votent
même quand l'abstention est très élevée
donc tout ça pour vous dire que tout ça
est lié souvent l'engagement s'est
cumulatif et que les jeunes qui votent
pas s'engagent pas non plus donc il y a
pas de de substitut
à l'engagement électoral et à
l'engagement institutionnel il faut
penser les deux ensemble
désolé il va falloir qu'on s'arrête là
c'était passionnant merci à vous quatre
et qu'on j'espère qu'on pourra continuer
ce débat d'ici d'ici peu de temps merci
au revoir merci au revoir
[Musique]